it's already been a damaging year for
the metropolitan police
and today the focus on scotland yard has
become even sharper placed in special
measures by a watchdog that answers to
parliament it's been earmarked as a
failing force and will be under
increased scrutiny required to report to
inspectors regularly
it's a rare move that comes after a
series of scandals the rape and murder
of sarah everard by serving officer
wayne cousins
failings in its investigation into the
killing of private detective daniel
morgan
and the strip search of a 15 year old
black school girl
an incident that prompted days of
protests
wait wait wait he didn't do anything the
inspectorate also referred to this
moment the stop in search of british
olympic sprinter bianca williams and her
partner
both were innocent
that catalogue of failings was followed
by a damning report on the conduct of
offices at charing cross station in
central london culminating in the
resignation of former commissioner
christa dick
mayor of london sadiq khan called for
her to go
i welcome
the police inspector at support today of
what i've been saying but also it's
really important
londoners have confidence in police and
i think londoners will feel vindicated
by the decision today from the police
inspectorate but what does this process
look like it begins with an urgent
action plan because the force is um
underperforming it's under a greater
degree of scrutiny than most other
forces in the country and that's an
unusual position for a large force to be
in and the force must rapidly come up
with a plan for solving the problems
that it has
there are just three other forces in
special measures this is drastic action
the inspector said it had persistent
concerns about elements of the mets
performance
the examples it highlights
have damaged public trust in britain's
biggest force
the met is still in the process of
hiring the new commissioner whoever they
appoint will face a series of searching
questions
shinki marike sky news scotland yard